Good afternoon Miss Ocean. As you know parole is a privilege.
It's a mistake.
Aaa..
But it happened
and umm
if i were to be released i would um
I would just want the simple life.
I just want to hold down a job, make some friends
Yeah, pay my bills
Even if this was possible you'll need 20 people
7 people
Why do you need to do this?
´Cuz it's what i'm good at
How long would it take you to make seven pieces of jewelry?
Five or six hours
How long if i told you you didn't have to live with your mother anymore
Less
What's your name?
Nine-ball
What's your real name?
Eight-ball
I'm going to be really poor
What if we could make all this go away?
Can I get my watch back, please?
And hers as well?
Sorry.
It's okay
I'm with my family I told you not
Come in the garage
You want me to tell you how big the job is?
No, I'm out
I'll tell you how big the job is
I'll be back before you know.
Can i come with you?
This is mommy's very special work trip
In three and a half weeks the MET will be hosting its annual ball
And we are going to rob it
Not the ball itself, but the neck of Daphne Kluger
Valued at over a hundred million dollars
It´s a hundred and fifty billion actually
Revenge it's a twofa
Do not run a job in a job
Can't we just go to this? Do we have to steal stuff?
Yes
Is it genetic of the whole family like this?
literally